rebouchez hier la faille ne cesse
pourtant de s'élargir centimètre par
centimètre
preuve s'il en était besoin que la masse
de terre de 75 mètres de long sur 20
mètres de haut continue a glissé en
contrebas
c'est justement au pied du talus que des
drains ont été disposés afin de purger
l'eau du sous-sol et retarde le
glissement toute l'eau qu'on va sortir
du talus elle est la meilleure de la
sécurité vous avez une rupture brutale
mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui très honnêtement on n'a pas
encore de d'éléments probants pour dire
on est sur une phase de ralentissement
continu à avoir des déplacements très
très très cynique et à toutes
le diagnostic et la surveillance
notamment aux abords des immeubles
voisins se poursuivent à l'aide
d'instruments de mesure et autres
fourrage quelles que soient les
conclusions des travaux devraient durer
au moins six mois au regard de l'ampleur
du 10 mai de terrain en attendant pour
tenter de soulager quelque peu les
automobilistes la ctm devrait réouvrir
partiellement certaines voix qui l'a
validé le président tout à l'heure ce
set
cette déviation qui permet de rétablir
la circulation sur une voie uniquement
pour les véhicules légers
donc ça va apporter une amélioration à
la situation mais bien sûr ne pas
permettre ne permettra pas de revenir à
la situation non le président du conseil
exécutif assure pour sa part évidemment
mettre tout en oeuvre en collaboration
avec la mairie de fort-de-france pour
traiter le problème
au bas mot puisque vous voulez l'egypte
au bas mot là elle est déjà mais nous
avons déjà dépensé au minimum 400
millions on n'est pas qu'aujourd'hui
lomé par rapport aux dégâts que vous
consacrez c'est sûr qu'il faut revenir
et nous n'avons pas la science infuse
malgré l'annoncé de la déviation qui
devrait être effective d'ici une
quinzaine de jours
les très nombreux usagers de la route
doivent s'attendre à de longues heures
d'embouteillages dans ce secteur déjà
traditionnellement compris